one day's am i right oh you're telling
me
hey how's old lady on and which one my
wife on my neighbor died you know so
what about yourself met this nice little
waitress down at the Denny's yeah yeah
yeah names Maria I've got to be careful
Becky doesn't find out no Becky doesn't
know what thing yeah hold on I'm getting
a phone call you hmm
hello three dozen roses you say hello
Jeff this company is saying they want to
give me a free dozen roses to send
anyone I want all I have to do is give
him a first name how about their
waitress down at Denny's I hate to break
it to you sounds like a scam I think
you're on a radio show buddy I'm sorry a
radio show no a radio show where a wife
calls in suspecting a husband's cheating
then they call him up offer him a dozen
roses if he picks his side-chick over
her they call him out on it do I think
you're getting set up yeah Jeff all they
need is a first name no last name no
street address no billing info nothing
they'll find her on their own how crazy
is that you're telling me some flower
business is gonna be able to track down
a woman by her first name what is this
the CIA you know the technology these
days twitter who knows I don't know I'm
gonna just tell you one more time
I think you're on a morning radio show I
mean what else do you want I I think
that's a coincidence I think deep down
that down Jeff that's kind of that going
in they just upped it to 53 roses Jeff
how could I throw down the deal I'm
gonna tell you right now you are 100%
definitely on a radio show right you've
been listening to too much radio I
should have never given you that thing
for Christmas you know what if you
actually think you're gonna get away
with it go for I do I do you know what
Jeff I'm gonna tell her name and the
name is Maria and I want you include a
note hey baby miss you can't wait to see
you this weekend
Becky how'd you get on the line I told
you that she got on the line oh my god
this is a radio show I told you you're
on a radio show I'll let you know right
now you just can't you can't trust those
things a little bit it's too good to be
true
Oh hold on can i phone
oh hello wow I just got off of the free
cruise all I have to say is if I'm gonna
take my wife on my neighbor yeah you
think her name's Carol